Welcome to the drama show the show where we talk about tips and tricks on how to
land a successful career in tech. In this show. Sometimes I have guests,
sometimes I don't like today. I don't have any guests.
Most of the time I will not have any guests because you know,
Silicon Valley people that are quite busy.
So today we're going to talk about how to land your first internship and how am
I going to talk about this? I'm going to talk about through my lens,
through my experiences, rather than telling you what to do.
I'll just tell you exactly what I did and not saying that's the best way to do
it, but I'm sharing my story after this video.
I'm going to talk about all my other internships, like for example,
how to get internship, Citadel, how to get an internship at LinkedIn,
how to transition into data science at Facebook,
and then how to transition again into PM at Microsoft. So yeah,
if you're interested in all those companies,
don't forget to press subscribe so that you get notified when those companies
come up. So, yeah. Welcome to Joe, Michelle.
I just want to say that, uh, I'm not going to tell you like, Oh yeah,
just work hard, you know, do practice questions and stuff like that.
The way I got things, it's not a hundred percent merit, you know? Uh,
I use a lot of my brother's connections. I, you know,
exaggerated my resume a lot. And I also did projects that I'd never completed,
but said I did. So to be honest, I don't want my friends knowing. And you know,
it's kind of, it's kind of embarrassing, but you know,
which is why I'm not promoting this challenge to them, but I'm telling you guys,
cause I want to be fully transparent. Cause our Arles in the end, I'm only,
I'm only going to be talking about like vague, you know?
And I don't want to talk about vape shop.
I just want to talk about concrete things on exactly how to get those
internships. All right. Okay. So let's get started. I'm going to,
I'm going to look at my old resume for reference,
cause it's been a while and I don't remember what exactly I did. So yeah,
as you can see, I have a, uh, I wrote a lot of cover letters.
That's how I started, but I just want to look at my resume.
I think it's this one. I'm not sure. Maybe. Maybe if I, okay. Wait,
it might be this one. Um, yeah, that's it. Okay. So work experience.
I still have no work experience. I worked at McDonald's and statistics, Canada.
I just knock on people's doors. Okay. Let's see. Okay.
This sounds about right now, actually I'm going to go longer.
One, is it this one? I had multiple resumes.
So yes.
The first thing I learned about getting internship is they told me to make my
resume one page. Cause like they don't have enough time to read all of them.
So I have one resume where I just have everything that co co accomplished,
but,
and then I shorten it depending on if I want to apply for finance or software.
Okay. Let me just try to remember what I did. Okay, cool.
Okay. I think I remember now, right?
So my first exposure into programming was CRC
robotics. This is something I did in high school.
It's not really high school. It's C Jeff, cause I'm from Quebec,
but you don't need to know what that is. CRC robotics. Basically.
We had to build robots and then we compete against each other.
And so for example,
one of the tests was that you had to program your robot to autonomously,
do a few things. So that's where programming came along.
So that was my first exposure.
It was called robot C apparently the language,
it just looks like C plus plus. And then, um,
my brother was also graduating from Waterloo,
which is the school that was going to go university of Waterloo.
And then he told me about computer science is that, Oh, you know,
you could have this thing called, uh,
code programs where you could write stuff and then you could input stuff and
then output stuff. You know, I thought it was a boring as ever,
but he told me that you could get like pretty sick jobs at Facebook and stuff
like that. So yeah. So then I started learning something called Dr.
Racket or scheme, which is stupid. Cause like I don't think any company uses it.
So I don't know I was learning that, but apparently it does.
The first thing you learn at school,
the first course is called like [inaudible] or something.
And then I dabble into that and then I learned about Python, what Python was.
So then I was doing that like Harvard classes, like online,
like the really easy ones. Okay. They're not really easy because um,
like I did the first course, I thought it was bomb.
And then when it comes to like object oriented shipment, what the?
And I just couldn't understand. So I didn't even pass that level.
So I had a very basic literacy of Python. Oh yeah. True. Okay.
I have to talk about my school because I think that's an important piece. Um,
so I went to university of Waterloo. I could tell you how I got in there,
but you probably don't need to because it's super easy to get into. Um,
Waterloo is pretty special in the fact that you have to get,
you have to do five to six internships before you graduate.
So they have this system called job mine,
and you have to apply to jobs using that system like every other semester.
And it makes getting internships a lot easier.
So if you have something like that in school,
make sure you take advantage of it because that's usually how you know,
you'll get your first tech internship.
Your first tech internship is usually the hardest one because you have no
experience and you only have side projects. If you have bomb side projects,
it's going to be pretty easy for you. If you don't, you should, you know,
do some, you don't need to finish them. To be honest,
you could even lie a little bit,
but just make sure that when you're asked questions about it,
you can answer them fully. Yeah.
So fast forward to like a year it's job fair. I mean,
we don't call it a job fair.
We have some program called job mine where you just, you know, put your resume,
put your cover letter and send it to companies. Let me show you something.
So here's the folder,
the folder that I use to all of the applications.
So I had a cover letter for each and every company. It was crazy.
It's basically the same thing,
but I just changed the name of the company and like the reasons why I'm a good
fit. Uh, I think I got about like a few responses, like maybe 10,
10 responses out of 50. And then I'll of those interviews.
I only got like one or I think two or three jobs.
I think one knows like QA position at like, um,
some Waterloo company. I don't remember what it was, but it was some basic.
And then I also got a first internship, which is
Scotia bank. So back to my resume, I'm going to tell you how I got that. Well,
how I think I got that first job. Cause um, I mean,
it's not exactly software engineering, but we did a lot of software engineering.
Like I did a lot of C plus Buster. I did some like VBA coding thing, which is,
um, not something software people would do, but yeah. So not going to lie.
The first job I got, it's not the best job ever. I mean, Scotiabank,
you probably, you, you probably don't even know what Scotiabank is.
It's a Canadian bank by the way. Uh, not prestigious at all. It's um, yeah,
it's crap to be honest, but the position was quite good. It's called credit. No.
What was it again? Equity and credit derivatives.
And I'll tell you a little bit about that and how I got into that.
So what credit in derivatives? Oh yeah. True. I forgot to talk about this.
I was in math and business. I wasn't computer science, uh, back then.
So I mean, I actually want to be like an investment banker or something.
I didn't even want to be a software engineer. Mostly.
I thought I was going to be an investment banker, so, or like a trader.
So I was really into finance stuff and I do two projects.
So the first project is in trade. Um,
so in trade was a website that you could bet on events. So how it works is,
for example, if you thought Obama was going to win the election,
then you have a marketplace for that. For example,
if the price is at nine and you buy at nine and Obama actually wins the
election, then it will automatically go to $10. So it's a one to 10 or sorry,
zero to 10. So then you would gain $1. If you've lost the election,
it would go to zero. So that means all the money invested,
the $9 invested you'll lose, you'll lose it on. It becomes zero.
So basically it's kind of like a stock market ish.
And then also my brother told me that, Oh, it's actually like a binary option.
I don't want to bore you with details, but basically in a finance world,
whatever I was playing with in that website, what were binary options?
And he told me that, Oh, do you want to work on project together?
My brother and I, and then I said, yeah, sure. Why not? So then he told me, Oh,
why don't you write a Python bot that trades these options
automatically? You know, I didn't really know anything about finance,
but then I learned, I learned that you could price a binary option.
I just went to Wikipedia. You could Google binary option.
And there's something called a black Sholes model that you can input your
numbers and then kind of have a guesstimate on how much it would cost.
And usually it'll be pretty accurate. So we did that for a couple of months,
I think. And I like, it was actually a really basic bond. It was terrible,
actually. It was like, no.
You know, like try catch.
Errors or whatever. It was pretty,
but I still did it and we still made money ish.
So then now I had like a pretty good fundamental knowledge on options for
trading. Yeah. And then the second project I did our ITC,
this is a Rotman international trading competition. It's not,
it's not technical at all. I mean, you, you have like Excel spreadsheets,
you write some VBA code to try to like facilitate your trading.
I basically wrote some VBA macros to facilitate in our pricing of the assets so
that we could trade.
I did really well on like a case that was like the options case.
So I understood like calls and puts, Ooh, I like, it's not a lot,
but it's enough to impress them as a freshmen. So I interviewed for Scotia bank.
I also interviewed for other companies about,
just talk about [inaudible] and then what they asked me was first asked me some
C plus plus related questions like, Oh,
what's object oriented programming stuff, inheritance and stuff like that.
And then they asked me some link lists questions. I remember, I think,
and then they also asked me like a binary search problem. Like for example,
can you use binary search to find, uh,
defined if a number exists? So it was a, I think they give you a,
an array of a sorted number. So first, you know, the, the,
the easiest solution would be, you know, just go linearly,
but that would be an event. Oh yeah. You have to know like your, your, um,
complexity, your time complexity. So,
so then first a brute force way is just like scan it linearly.
And then later on to say, can't do it any better.
And then that's where you pull out the binary research method. And then I think,
I think that's, it that's like the, like the hardest questions there.
So it was pretty simple. Cause I mean, it's a finance company.
They don't ask you a hardship next. They asked me some call and put options.
I think they asked they, they drew like a line, which is like the payout line.
And then they told me like, Oh, what combination of calls and puts is that?
And can you tell me like how to combine them so that your payout option that
looks like that? Sorry,
I'm talking about this because it's not really software related,
but that's what they asked me. And then, yeah.
So then I got that question right.
And then went home and then they called me back like a week later and they said
that I was like the number one candidate for them.
And then they want to offer me a job. That was great.
I got the job and that's how I got my first internship.
So that's pretty much it. Um, yeah. Let me see if I,
if I forgot anything. Oh yeah, yeah. True. So I guess,
um, I did a lot of random too,
and I'll tell you things that are kind of like iffy, that might've helped,
but also might not have helped. And also like that actually didn't do.
But I wrote that I did. So here you could see, I got Facebook hacker cup,
you know, I wrote annual worldwide program competition hosted by Facebook,
develop problem, solving skills through completing their protein puzzles.
I didn't even do any of them. I think I did like one or two.
I got one of them and then I failed theater too.
Like I didn't even make it to the second round pie game.
I made like a stupid game using PI yeah. Using PI game.
I think it was just like a ball that runs around and shoots like balls at,
at things. And then Google AI challenge. Oh, that's the worst.
I didn't even do that. So basically the Google AI challenge, I remember it was,
uh, as a game of plant Wars,
there there's a nerd game like this that you could play for real,
like not using bots, it's a GIF planets.
And then you could shoot spaceships onto another planet to capture it if you
have more spaceships and theater planet. But yeah.
So you could program a bot to play that game, but I didn't even do it.
Like I think I just downloaded the sample bot and changed like a few parameters
and just tried it out. But I couldn't like,
I didn't even know how to run it or like test it and stuff.
So I didn't even do that by, so put it in there and also had some stupid,
like just to fill in my resume, like poker, you know,
because I thought that's for trading like old traders love poker.
So I talked about my poker mom, this is actually real. Like,
I'm pretty proud of my poker games and my profit there.
I even put like my art stuff. I don't know why I put, uh, Oh yeah.
I guess I have to say that. Um,
I did get good grades in school so that might've helped. Uh, yeah.
Waterloo has like cumulative average of 93. So I was in Dean's honors list.
So yeah. Uh,
never be discouraged at your first internship because after you get one good
internship,
all the other big companies will just come knocking your door and you're just
get like a ton of interviews. So, yeah. So in conclusion,
that was how I got my first tech internship and it wasn't a great tech
internship because it was like a no-name tech internship and it was, um,
like C plus plus crap code base was. You know, their tech was really bad,
but it was my first job and it kind of led to how I got into Citadel.
And they'll talk about that on my next video. So yeah. Thanks for watching.
Don't forget to subscribe if you want to know how I got into Citadel,
which I will post, uh, next time, I guess. And then yeah. Thanks for watching.